[Música]
hola muy buenas pues bueno la vida la
vida cambia a veces te da sorpresas
cuando menos te lo esperas
porque y sobre todo la sorpresa si son
desagradables nunca son buenas nunca
vienen bien y entonces bueno pues en
estas cosas también en mi caso me
sorprendió como decía santos pues con
una enfermedad cuando menos me lo
esperaba
y me trabajo aquí se puede decir que
aquello me trajo aquí un poquito pues
para hablar de lo que es de donación de
generosidad etcétera este tipo de cosas
de dar oportunidades hoy se habló
también aquí dar nuevas oportunidades ha
hablado de trasplantes antes en cuanto a
médula y se habla de todo ese tipo de
cosas y se habló de cosas muy
interesantes al respecto a mí bueno yo
me pasó que cuando yo venía unas
vacaciones hacía unos cuantos años
venían una moto venía con la moto con
unos amigos
y nada me puse malo de repetir me marea
y me dio un mareo además un poco extraño
porque parecía que perdí el conocimiento
de hecho no estuve a punto de perderlo
por los síntomas que tiene y bueno me
parece adelante m para ella me puse un
poquito mejor continuó el viaje todo fue
muy bien pero ya cuando llegue a
pamplona yo soy de pamplona
a los días me empieza encontrar otra vez
un poquito que ahorita bueno la cosa es
que me fui a urgencias ya era una cosa
un poco más fuerte me fui a urgencias y
me quedé ingresado
y nada después de unas cuantas pruebas
lo que me dijeron que lo que tenía era
insuficiencia renal crónica que es una
enfermedad que afecta a los riñones que
hace que vayan que no funcionen bien era
diagnosticada por pierna y british
crónica que se llama que es una
infección que el mono que van dañando
hasta que al final lo que tiene esta
enfermedad además es una es una cosa muy
característica que no da la cara hasta
que está muy avanzado hasta que ya
prácticamente no se pueda hacer nada
entonces bueno pues así así entonces de
la noche a la mañana como decían yo era
profesor de kickboxing una vida sana
pues siempre había me había cuido mucho
había lleva una vida sana y al final te
encuentras con una enfermedad
lamentándote también note las heridas y
maldiciendo tu mala suerte no al final
es un poco es un poco aquellas sorpresas
de las que hablamos
entonces al final como las cosas pueden
empeorar empeoraron en mi caso por
supuesto esto fue a peor y lo que y lo
que tiene esta enfermedad tiene algo de
bueno con respecto a otras y es que te
puede terminar en un trasplante no
poniendo otro órgano y en mi caso bueno
pues cuando cuando ya no había nada que
hacer cuando esto llegó a las últimas
había que hacer el trasplante yo me
sentí en ese momento muy
me sentí muy abrumado por la generosidad
sobre todo de mis familiares de mis
amigos yo recuerdo me vino mi hermano y
me dijo no te preocupes yendo al médico
y ya he hecho todo tipo de pruebas y te
puedo el riñón y el monólogo me llamo mi
hermana me dijo porque él porque no yo y
tal monas y es una cuestión mi sobrino
me decía que me lo quería dar un amigo
de o tranquilos y vamos a sólo editó uno
fue una cosa muy fuerte yo a veces yo
cuando escribía esto cuando cuando están
pensando en esta charla intenté buscar
palabras que describir ser un poco de
esa emoción no es ese sentimiento yo
creo que no las encontré es muy difícil
de explicar no es ese sentimiento de que
te sientes arropado no de ese la verdad
es que me sentí muy abrumado y bueno
pues por supuesto muy bien entonces
cuando llegó el momento me lo iba me lo
iba a dar en principio hasta ahora hay
una serie de pruebas que hay que hacer
pero una llamada de madrugada
bueno esto es así puede ser que haya un
donante cada vez de ese momento me
llamaron y una llama de madrugada pues
me llevo a la clínica
otra vez no sé si funciona si pensaba
que se había ido un poco el sonido aquí
me quedo otra vez y me tras faltar a mi
hermano se libró y ahí bueno cuando yo
desperté a la operación yo creo que lo
que baja el quirófano mono baja es un
baja 1 ya como diciendo que sea lo que
tenga que ser porque te encuentres en un
estado de salud un poco lamentable ya y
cuando desperté todo iba bien
afortunadamente había estaría funcionar
muy bien
me sentía estupendamente no me levantaba
y me iba a correr porque tenía una
herida que me lo impedía pero la verdad
es que es una sensación impresionante yo
la primera noche además recuerdo que me
la pasé llorando me estaba cuidado una
enfermedad yo no paraba de llorar y
medición porque yo era así decía claro
es que hay alguien que se ha muerto para
que yo tenga para que esté bien para que
yo esté vivo esté aquí y esto es muy
bien parece que no aún pero es te pones
a pensar en ello hoy y así me pasé toda
la noche que me decía no te preocupes se
habría muerto igual de bueno me quedé
más tranquilo bueno eso es una aparece
así gracias sí pero es pero es muy
fuerte en aquel momento es un poco bueno
pues la cuestión es que vaya me recupere
me fui a casa
claro después de una vida haciendo un
deporte tienes que cambiar un poquito y
al principio empecé a andar
y bueno poco a poco a los pocos días
estaba corriendo la cinta primero 15
minutos 20 ver un día regulo muy
emocionante estaba corriendo lleva una
hora corriendo fue fue muy chulo muy
emocionante porque estás haciendo algo
que no hacían se hace mucho tiempo que
no podías hacer porque no te lo permitía
la salud no y es muy muy muy muy bonito
la verdad que voy a
bueno la cuestión
la cuestión es que al final vas
corriendo luego te acabas hacia dos días
lone se ha conseguido carreras de todo
tiempo yo creo que esto es natural no
una cosa va directamente y banda la otra
luego me puse acerca de obstáculos esto
es muy bueno no sé si alguien ha hecho
una carga obstáculos es como un chiqui
park para mayores está súper bien que
sean acuerdo a pasas te tiras al río te
llenas de barro esta es muy divertido
y bueno y esta es un poco lo que está es
un poco la historia no yo creo que de
todo esto de todo esto lo que yo me
quedo con más lo que a mí se me queda
más arraigado lo que yo me quedo más
más fuertemente dentro es el aprovechar
las cosas es decir el no preocuparnos
muchas veces lo decía también así antes
que nos preocupamos demasiado por cosas
que no son tan importantes a veces que
pasamos por alto las cosas que de verdad
mente si lo son los meramente si lo son
que son las más sencillas muchas veces
pasamos sin darnos cuenta preocupándonos
por cosas que no y realmente lo que lo
que lo que nos hace sentir lo que nos
hace estar bien lo dejamos un poquito de
lado y debería ser comenta mente al
revés no yo creo que eso es
y que se te queda cuando pasas por
ciertas circunstancias aprendes
lamentablemente cuando estás con cuando
tienes algo que te pasa algo así es
cuando aprendes cosas o cuando te das
cuenta yo creo que deberíamos todo
reflexionar un poquito sobre ese tipo de
cosas y luego nada como decía antes
estoy aquí por aquella llamada por una
llamada de madrugada en la que en la que
una familia en el momento más difícil o
normalmente los momentos más difíciles
de la vida de su vida que es cuando
perdió un ser querido han tenido en el
acto de generosidad que es más más
bonito que hay que es el dar vida no el
regalar el dar una vida en salvar una y
varias vidas porque son varias vidas las
que se salvan el dar oportunidad a
personas que están llegando a ese
momento ya un poco límite de volver a
experimentar de volver a vivir de volver
a hacerlo bien o mal y de volver a
sentir esas cosas entonces
es una llamada a una llamada de
esperanza es lo que me trajo y que es
más que hay más bonito ya lo hemos
hablado antes también y más importante
que la esperanza no muchas gracias
[Aplausos]